all right some of you are going to be
mad at me for covering this story but I
would be a partisan hypocrite if I
didn't cover this story except the other
half of you are going to be mad at me
for covering this story the way that I'm
going to cover it there is a video
floating around in which The Story Goes
Joe Biden appears very very visibly
confused at a speech last week where
after speaking he turned and he tried to
shake hands with thin air and then
looked so confused on the stage and
didn't know where to go and he has
dementia and he has Alzheimer's and it's
worse than Trump and all of this
different stuff and I'll tell you when
over the weekend the clip was sent to me
and I looked on added on my small phone
screen
very quickly
it looked very bad Joe Biden looked
confused it looked like he was shaking
hands with the air thinking there was
someone standing next to him and there
was no one there and I was getting ready
to come to you and say guys I mean
listen we have a dozen examples of trump
with this type of stuff I've got to tell
you that we have one with Joe Biden
except then I actually looked at the
video that was not cropped uh into a
sort of uh vertical video where you
actually see the sides of what's going
on
and
um it actually is fine Joe Biden is very
clearly speaking to people on different
sides of him and signaling to them with
his hand yes it looks weird he's
sticking it out almost like a handshake
but he points to the people uh to the
right and he turns around and he points
to people that were over his left
shoulder and over his right shoulder and
that's just kind of it I mean it's we're
going to look at it and
um once I saw the full video it really
just kind of seems like no big deal so
I'm gonna play it for you
and I know that if you're only listening
you're not really going to get the full
picture of this but let's take a look at
it and then I'll explain it and we'll go
from there
[Music]
America the United States of America
[Music]
thank you
so I mean listen I I was I was ready to
say
something's wrong with Joe Biden we got
to evaluate Joe Biden but when you
actually look at what he's doing he he's
engaging with each wing of the crowd and
he's saying something I don't know if
it's like how was it or uh thanks for
being here but he's very clearly turning
to the people on his right and he says
something and then he turns and faces
back and he does the exact same thing
you see his arm do the exact so I don't
want to belabor this but it's not what
it initially appeared to be that that's
just kind of it and I would tell you
guys when Trump looked confused and lost
right when Trump got off of his plane
and his limos his car is right in front
of him and he seems to wander off and
literally a secret service agent comes
over and takes him by the arm and turns
him around and walks him back towards
his car he seemed very confused and
there was no real simple explanation for
that uh when Donald Trump said he wanted
to know the oranges of an investigation
and he kind of like glitches and he
knows that what's coming out of his
mouth doesn't make sense he wants to say
Origins and he's saying oranges and he
tries again and it doesn't that was
really weird there's been no real
explanation for that not even a simple
one when Rudy Giuliani was sitting right
across from Trump at a table and Trump
says where is Rudy and he's looking
around and Rudy's as close as uh you
know not as close as my microphone but
right across the table there was no
explanation for that and and I told you
that
and when Joe Biden has completely lost
his train of thought I've told you that
really doesn't look good that's not his
stutter Joe Biden has had a lifelong
stutter uh when he completely loses his
train of thought
and says well okay let me move on
because they don't want me talking about
this it just seems like he's losing his
train of thought and I've told you guys
um this video is not what many are
making it out to be
um what what I uh I I don't even know
what else to say does Biden sometimes
sound confused yeah he does and I don't
like when it happens it makes me
uncomfortable does sometimes uh does Joe
Biden sometimes lose his train of
thought yeah absolutely but this video
as The Smoking Gun dementia video I I
just don't see it guys if you disagree
with me I want you to let me know
one of our sponsors is athletic greens
which makes comprehensive daily
nutrition really simple people are busy
we're not always getting effective
balanced nutrition from the food we eat
we sometimes are combining all sorts of
different vitamins supplements different
things that may be relevant to us ag1 by
athletic greens is a delicious drink
that just simplifies the entire thing
it's one product you get all of the
things you need 75 vitamins minerals and
Whole Food sourced ingredients it's a
multivitamin it's a multi-mineral it's a
probiotic green food blend in one daily
serving really easy high quality bio
available ingredients can fill those
nutritional gaps in your diet and they
can help with gut health and digestion
and support you in other ways and they
can replace multiple products and pills
that you might be taking it's just one
drink really simple I've been enjoying
the ag1 drink by athletic greens tastes
good helps me get everything I'm trying
to get athletic greens is giving my
audience a free one-year supply of
vitamin D and five free travel packs
with your first purchase when you go to
athletic greens.com Pacman the link is
in the podcast notes